[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul aka
the guy who's been living la vida loki
and whilst we wait for season two i
thought we'd re-examine the ending of
the marvel show
one more time you daft punk now the
finale culminated with loki and sylvie
arriving at the citadel
which existed at the end of time here
they met he who remains who gave them
a choice they could either take over the
position or destroy him
and nurse usher in a world of timelines
in which an infinite amount of his evil
variants would rise up
sylvie chose to do the latter and
because of this she's been ranked
amongst the likes of star lord
and boris johnson when it comes to
making good decisions
the internet naturally took it very well
and none of the writers received any
hate or abuse on twitter
and now by that i mean they did and
though i didn't initially think that it
was the right choice
over the last couple of weeks the more
i've thought about it the more that i
think it was
on top of this i actually believe that
he who remains knew she would do this
and that he purposely made her believe
she had free will when it was always
going to go his way
now in order to argue why sylvie might
have been right i think we have to
discuss who she is
as a character sylvie lived a relatively
normal life in asgard
until one day she was plucked from the
time stream by the tva
and put on trial we never learned what
her nexus event was
and the character doesn't even know it
herself it seemed completely unfair and
unjust and because of this it laid a
hatred within the character
very early on selby managed to escape
the hearing
and she spent the rest of her life on
the run hiding out at the end of
apocalypses
whilst the tva hunted her throughout the
series she said she didn't have one
positive memory before meeting
loki and this speaks to how miserable
her life was
as we know as guardians can live for
thousands of years
and who knows how many days sylvie spent
looking over her shoulder in constant
fear that the tva would catch her
selfie knows first hand what it's like
to be the enemy of the organization
and how much misery that it can lead to
it's clear that because of this
she would never be someone who would
head up the tva they are fascists and
throughout our own history we've seen as
organizations like this have tried to
stamp down other ways of life
you would never expect the oppressed to
join them and then
make others suffer the same way that
they have it would actually show a
character flaw
rather than a strength which i believe
that sylvie's choice demonstrates
even if silvi wanted the tva to act
humanely there's simply no way to wipe
someone from existence
on the off chance that they might lead
to an evil variant of kang
even with the best intentions selfie's
tva would inevitably fall into either
enlisting or exterminating people
in case they led to something worse down
the line the tva agents themselves don't
seem to have much of a life
and they're pretty much slaves that
don't get paid or given the choice of
how they want to live their lives
mobius and mobius constantly yearns just
to ride a jet ski
but he'll never get the chance as long
as he's there because of this we know he
who remains was using fear to control
people
and he pretty much made it so it was
either his way or the highway
he who remains even scares loki into
thinking that the pair should take over
even though the both of them went there
to take the tva down
now another point that i want to bring
up is that the situation they find
themselves in
isn't sylvie's fault it's kang's now had
kang not turned out to be one of the
worst tyrants of all time
then the tva would never need to be
created and the multiversal war wouldn't
happen
the famous saying is we should never
negotiate with terrorists
and though they aren't trying to make
deals with kang it's clear the tva
are saying certain people shouldn't live
their lives just because of him
you can't live in fear of what might
happen and if you restrict yourself and
the way you live
because it might lead to someone acting
evil then you've already lost whilst
they've won
there's really no positive outcome for
this and either countless lives are lost
because kang rises up and starts a war
or they're lost because the tva pruned
people both situations are bad
but in the former at least people will
have free will and can make choices
which i'll talk about in just a bit
now killing he remains means that a
resistance can at least meet kang
and judging by the way that the mcu has
gone so far i do think that we will see
a multiversal war
but that the good guys will come out of
it triumphant it's better to fight for
what you believe in than to bow before a
dictator
and i love how this show tackles deep
messages like this now if you're
enjoying the video and the arguments so
far then i'd massively appreciate the
thumbs up
also don't forget to subscribe as we do
deep dives on a lot of marvel shows and
movies
i'd love to have you as part of the
family you might even be
my variant my brother from another
mother or sister
and if you are then maybe we should kiss
now
sorry i'm moving on that's inappropriate
now moving on we should we should look
at the themes of the show
namely the one of free will versus
conformity throughout we've watched as
those in positions of power have tried
to force loki and silvi to see things
from their point of view
and they've completely removed the
choice for them to live their lives the
way that they want
sylvie killing he who remains and
demonstrating that she has free will
whilst allowing the multiverse to spring
forth
very much shows that the series airs on
the side of choice
rather than oppression salvi is giving
the entire multiverse
the choice to do what they want and
because of this she will have saved
trillions of lives that would have been
destroyed by the tva
now as i touched upon earlier i do
actually think that this was all part of
he who remains master plan
as we learn in the show time is a flat
circle and should a multiversal war
happen
then a variant of kang will rise up to
oppose this
this character will then go on to become
he who remains
a man that prunes all of the branches of
the timeline until there's just one
from this sylvie and lucky will rise
once more and they will go to stop him
which will start the entire cycle all
over again
who knows how many times this entire
thing has happened beforehand
but i very much think that he remains
wanted things to go a certain way
so that he could die and pretty much
restart the entire process all over
again
everything we see is all part of his
master plan and this would explain why
he has a script up to a certain point
that details everything that's going to
happen throughout time he could just
keep constantly passing the script to
himself
over and over and over again ensuring
that everything we see happens forever
as this will always lead to a version of
kang being in control
though he says he's doing it to stop
other variants from ruling
he himself is very much ruling over the
entire multiverse
and though he seems like a nice guy on
the surface he's as bad as the corrupt
and evil monsters that he claims to be
fighting
therefore in the end when we weigh it
all up i do think that sylvie was in the
right and that she was correct in
removing him from power
here was a woman who had been on the run
since she was a girl
and had things in the show being framed
slightly differently then she would very
much be
the hero of this story the multiversal
war is coming but with that is the hope
that the marvel characters will be able
to defeat kang
without he who remains rising up and
that will no doubt lead to a better
future
obviously i'd love to hear your thoughts
on this video and whether you disagree
with sylvie's actions
or you know you think she did the right
thing comment below and let me know and
just to let you know
we're currently running a competition
right now and giving away three mcu box
sets on the 30th of july
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on and
drop a comment below with your thoughts
on the video
we picked the comments at random at the
end of the month and the winners of the
last one are on screen right now
so if that's you then message me on
twitter heavyspoilers
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
kang
and all of the variants that we could be
seeing in the mcu
we've made a very comprehensive video
about his origins powers
and which of our favorites we think will
be popping up so definitely go watch it
right after this
without the way thank you for sending
through the video i've been poor i'll
see you next time
take care peace
you